-My first guest is
an Oscar, Golden Globe,
and seven-time Emmy winner,
starring on
the hit comedy series "Mom,"
which is airing its
eighth and final season
Thursdays at 9:00 p.m. on CBS.
Here is Allison Janney!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
Oh, I'm so happy you're here.
Allison Janney!
You look fantastic.
-Jimmy --
-Thank you.
-Jimmy, I can't --
I mean, I cannot believe
that I'm finally
meeting you this way.
But this is the first time
I'm doing your show.
And I just want to ask you
why have you taken so long
to ask for me to be here?
-That sounds so bizarre to me.
I feel like we've had
great interviews.
-We have?
-Haven't we?
-No, we haven't.
-Yeah.
-This is our
first interview together.
-Oh, well, this is
going to be memorable.
-I'm a virgin,
so be kind and gentle.
-We'll never forget this day --
April 14th.
4-1-4...
-4-1-4 is our date.
-...will forever be
in our hearts.
-I love you.
I'm so happy to be here.
-I love you. I'm a big fan.
And you're fantastic.
I want to get into
so many things.
But let's talk about "Mom."
You wrapped up,
finished filming.
This is eight seasons.
This is 170 episodes.
It's got to be emotional.
Is it bittersweet?
What is it?
-You know what? It's everything.
As everything is,
it's never one thing.
Sometimes, I'd be
driving on the lot,
and it was like, "Oh, my God.
This is the last Monday I'll be
driving on
the Warner Bros. lot."
And I was filming myself.
And, of course, that one day,
it was a guard
who didn't know me.
So it was like, you know,
"Can I see your I.D.?"
And I was like, "It's me!"
You know, and, no,
he didn't know who I was.
But then I'd come on,
and just everything
would make me cry.
And then, the next day,
I'd come on and feel like,
"I'm so excited this is ending.
I get a new chapter of life."
It was the biggest, you know,
emotional roller-coaster ride.
And, sometimes, people would be
sobbing, and I'd feel nothing.
And I'd be like,
"What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me?"
And then the
next -- You know, it was --
Literally everyone
was all over the place.
And it was really sad.
We all -- It was such a family
we had there, so we're sad.
We're sad we're not coming back
to tell more of these stories,
'cause I think
it's so important.
And, you know, it's so great
when you get to entertain people
but also put something
out there in the world
that helps destigmatize
something like recovery
and make it
more approachable to people.
And it's done so much
for so many people.
It just -- I get tons of letters
and fans coming up to me
so appreciative of what
the show has done for them.
-Yeah! Thank you for
doing that, by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is -- it is -- it is great
when you can do both.
Did you steal
any props or anything?
-Well, just between
you and me...
-Yeah, no one's watching.
-I did -- I had to --
It's funny,
because no one knew I was
wearing a wig.
And I come in for
this season of "Mom,"
and the producers
see me like this.
And they're like,
"What have you done?!
How are we going to do --
You should have asked us before
you did this to your hair."
And I'm like, "Guys, I've been
wearing a wig since Season 1."
But nobody knew it.
So, everybody in the world
knows it now.
But -- So, that wig
is coming with me.
And a few pairs of sweatpants,
'cause my character, Bonnie,
loved to be comfortable,
as does Allison Janney.
So I took a lot of those --
a lot of sweatpants.
-You were -- Do you know what
you're going to do next?
'Cause you've done theater and
you knocked it out of the park.
You've done movies.
You knocked it out of the park.
You do drama, you knock it --
Sitcom, knock it
out of the park.
What's next for you?
-Well, I decided to,
as I like to do all the time,
whatever I've done --
the last thing I've done,
I like to shake it up and do
something completely different.
So I've decided, Jimmy,
that I'm going to go do
an action-thriller movie,
and I'm about to start training
with a fight trainer
two hours a day
and learn to fight to kill
and to be a bad-ass,
like, you know,
female Dirty Harry
in this movie called "Lou"
that I'm about to start filming.
-Wow! Already,
the audience is into it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to see this.
This is fantastic.
-Yeah.
Say a prayer that
I survive it, you know,
'cause it's going to be --
It'll be pretty cool.
-Oh, you're going to be great!
-I hope so.
-Can I quickly ask?
The sleeping dog behind you --
what's its name?
-Yes. Well, that's Dutch.
And Dutch is my protector.
And he's very interested in
our interview, you can see.
-Oh, yeah.
He looks like one of
those protective dogs, yeah.
-Oh, he is.
He actually --
He's a cattle dog,
so he likes to nip at people's
heels, which is not --
You know, most guests
who come into my house,
I give them ankle guards
so they don't get bit by Dutch.
But he is a sweetheart.
-Well, he is also making his
debut on "The Tonight Show,"
so this really will be
a memorable --
I knew this interview
would be memorable.
It's you and Dutch.
-I wish the other dogs
would come here, but --
I got two more around here
somewhere, but they're shy.
-Allison, congrats on the
success of "Mom" and everything.
And please come on
the show more often.
I'd like to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Allison Janney in
tomorrow night's episode
of "Mom."
Take a look.
-What you got going on there?
-Oh, I need to hold on to
the lumber
when I make a turn,
and I got a splinter.
I'm gonna start wearing
gloves when I drive.
-That's your solution?
-Yeah, mittens would make it
too hard to change the radio.
-Or perhaps the time
has come to buy a truck.
-Oh, she can't afford a truck.
-Whoa! Bonnie just said what
the voice in my head
said at the exact same time.
-That means my voice
is in your head.
That's a good thing.
That saves lives.
-I bet you can afford it.
You're very cheap --
I-I mean, frugal.
-I'm not sure I'm ready.
-I miss my red socks.
-Are you okay?
Is she having a stroke?
Do you smell toast?
Wait. I smell toast.
Am I having a stroke?
No, we're in a diner.
Carry on.
-Yeah. I love it.
Allison Janney, everybody!
Catch the final season of "Mom"
Thursdays at 9:00 p.m. on CBS.